you guys
[Music]
a genre that's taken over the anime
world I feel that the momentum of the
series reached its peak a couple of
years ago those starting out watching
seasonals these years don't know how
much of a meme isakai was back in the
mid to late 2010s plus I've taken it
upon myself to give you a trip back in
time to a time when the isakai craze was
at its Zenith which is to say not too
far ago but for the sake of sticking to
the theme I'll be listing what I feel
are the top 20 action isakai from the
past two decades or so action izakai
means those with a focus on action so as
much as I want to include some of my
favorite shows like ascendance of a
bookworm or your boy Kong Ming left to
sit this one out starting out the list
we have a newcomer reincarnated as a
sword
[Music]
foreign
on fire you know and that's not
unexpected given that it's a show that
shared a season with chainsaw man blue
lock Eminence in Shadow and a lot of
sequels oh and body fever also took over
big time but if we take away all of
those big hits reincarnated as a sword
stands out as one of the better titles
in the crowd of mid-tier shows at first
glance the story seems simple besides
the unique premise of the protagonist
becoming a sword and for the most part
the story stays in form it won't blow
your mind or anything like that
admittedly then why is it on this list
you're probably thinking well it's
simply entertaining to watch the
protagonist and Fran grow together their
chemistry and how they play off each
other is quite impeccable and it makes
it one of the isakais that entertain me
quite a bit characters can help carry a
show as the case of something like
licorice recoil and for me the same
thing albeit with lesser effect you know
can be said of reincarnated as a sword
cautious hero however turns up the
comedic aspect of things
wow
you can never be too careful as they say
so the most effective way of fulfilling
your goal in a dangerous fantasy world
is to min max your stats and take all
possible precautions but what if you
take that premise and turn it up to 11.
we've got this entertaining it's a guy
that gave me a good mix of both action
and comedy like reincarnated as a sword
however cautious hero lives and dies by
how well you find The Chemistry Between
the main leads and to me I found myself
in stitches watching the two in this
show that technically feels like a
sitcom Sayer and ristata is bickering
and interactions remind me of konosuba
specifically Aqua I'm sure I'm not the
only one but the comedic undertones of
this show extend to even the villains
because in a world where the hero is
overly cautious you also have villains
who plan ahead in hilariously over the
top ways too moving past the wackiness
of this show however you can see a title
that soon stands on its own as a
captivating adventure with Stakes of
course these do pale in comparison to
the darker or more serious ones out
there but cautious hero does put in some
effort to it and I think it works out
pretty fine
hello
that got you energized right well it's
the perfect time now to introduce
today's sponsors Tokyo treat and
sakurako if you've been loyally tuning
into my videos then you're likely to
know these guys but for those who don't
Tokyo treat and sakurako are two
subscription-based snack boxes that aim
to let people from all over the world
experience the unique joys of Japan
right on their doorstep the two boxes
have their fair share of differences
though Tokyo tree caters more to those
looking for the rare exclusive and
limited edition snacks that you can get
from Japan each Tokyo treat box comes
with up to 20 snacks meanwhile sakurako
caters more to those looking to
experience the more Artisan side of
Japanese snack culture each sakurako box
comes with 20 snacks plus it comes with
some Nifty kitchenware too for this
month the two boxes come together to
bring you the joys of yozakura use it
even if springtime's almost over you can
still experience the last few weeks of
the Season through these themed snacks
all centered around the nighttime
viewing of Sakura blossoms Tokyo tree
brings you the Sakura Starlight starfest
featuring some flavors that you probably
haven't tasted before Sakura matcha and
Sakura Cherry Bouche on the sakurako
side of things it's moonlit Sakura theme
box will bring you stuff like Sakura
Army and Sakura sweet potato they all
look really delicious so the right thing
to do is to check out the links in the
description box and get your
subscription now do you remember grimgar
well do now
story
speaking of character-centric stories
grimgar is a top Contender for a show
that takes time to get the ball rolling
it actually ended up being a detriment
to the show's popularity in my opinion
but Grim guards one of the most Slow
Burn issachars I've ever watched for
those who can get through the first Epps
that are heavily focused on
characterization and build up however
you do get a story that's worth the wait
towards the end I mean sure it's not as
hype as you'd expect out of an it's a
guy especially one that's marketed as
quite actually however I think it does
bring with it its own signature flavor
in the saturated world of issaka it also
has unique presentation in terms of the
visuals and the art style so Grim guard
definitely does bring a one-of-a-kind
experience to anyone looking to watch it
especially those who grew up in the more
modern isakai shows
and yes I just had to put out the spider
is a guy next because I just talked
about presentation and visuals not their
spider truly excels in anything of that
sort if anything it's one of the shows
rather mediocre aspects actually the
visuals in the presentation I mean it
looks clunky and all but to me it
doesn't really detract from the good
that the show has to offer this show in
spite of its rather simple premise
that's all for a world that's far beyond
what I've come to expect I expected a
pretty basic Underdog Story of Survival
and Rising Up Against All Odds what I
got was something that's admittedly
convoluted for my expectations but not
that that's a bad thing because I just
love it when the scale of a show
escalates to include clashing ideologies
politics and the like everything gets
helped with a very lovable and
charismatic lead and you have here a
story that's pretty fun to get through
if you can stomach the CG please
oh
speaking of CG I give you a refurata
if you thought spider CGI was bad how
about Arif you read that and it's
PlayStation 1 monsters I mean all
kidding aside oh if you read that it's
probably a name you've heard of it's
become one of the poster children for
edgy Revenge Issa guys where a betrayed
hero Rises up and rallies against the
world and it's easy to see why you know
the show's unapologetically over the top
and edgy yet beyond all the two nebio
aspects and the stuff that 15 year olds
would love I found myself enjoying the
plot a lot that as well as seeing
hajime's relationship with this
ever-growing traveling party develop as
they fight against the World season two
does up the ante a little bit with the
plot and the hilariously bad CG does get
fixed it's totally worth a show if these
kinds of shows are your type and I
unironically say that season 2 was one
of the shows I looked forward to
watching the most every week back in his
season season two is probably one of the
best comebacks a show made and the
difference in production quality is just
night and day next in line is skeleton
night in another world
thank you
[Music]
have you ever seen a show that one look
and you can't help but feel that it just
seemed inspired by something then enter
skeletonite in another world starring
Ark a skeleton is a guy protagonist
who's yeah Arc not irons mind you and
this is a skeleton protag who's a lot
nicer and more laid back actually he's
somewhat who takes things easily unless
you're one of the vile villains abusing
the elves in this world that's actually
a lot more evil than you think at first
glance a stark contrast to how colorful
and vibrant everything looks I do think
that the strongest suit of the show is
that it creates an image of a world that
you'll find yourself pretty comfortable
in that chill jrpg vibe that some people
have always wanted plus a corrupt World
under the sunshine and rainbows the show
has its fair share of controversies mind
you it's not opposed to showing some
sensitive content and all I think it's a
pretty sure it's a guy if you step back
and look at it with a different lens
it's nothing really groundbreaking in
terms of being unique or anything like
that but it could be worth a try for
issakai enthusiasts
Gates was one of the shows I watched in
my college Years it's nice to be able to
talk about it
foreign
as an adult anime fan there are a few
protagonists that can resonate as
closely to me as Itami Yuji his
escapades as a member of the jsdf is
something that I for the most part
enjoyed the show also has quite the
Nifty setup for an isakai instead of
everyone being forcibly transported into
the fantasy world it's them ethami and
the rest of the army that spend the most
part willingly in that world helping out
or otherwise intervening in their
politics all while showing off the
superiority of the Glorious Japanese
weaponry and Military yeah that last
statement was a joke even if I said the
statement almost ironically from the
get-go the show so obviously a love
letter to the Japanese military with
people going as far as making jokes
about how this is a subtle recruitment
letter done in an anime form as such
you'll see some themes and scenes that
are so heavily Pro jsdf but that doesn't
really detract from the experience in my
opinion and it's very cool gate is still
a pretty badass story that features its
share of hype moments and comedy brought
about by the numerous Fish Out of Water
scenarios are heroes and their new
friends from the fantasy world find
themselves in
[Music]
world's finest assassin is another new
Hot Shot that showed a lot of potential
invite the smell here
have you ever wondered why it's always
the otaku's in the everyday salarymen
who get transported to another world
with a mission to defeat the demon lord
well besides meta reasons that we Savvy
fans know that does beg a question
however that's not an issue here in this
show we're a grizzled assassin in life
dies and gets reincarnated into this
fantasy world of course if your quest is
to defeat the former hero there's no
better person for the job Luke as our
protagonist is now known begins his new
training in this new world looking to
incorporate his new and growing
knowledge of magic and his cold-blooded
techniques from his previous life he
prepares to deal with the hero meeting
new comrades and dangerous enemies along
the way a really refreshing anime from
the brain behind redo of healer yeah
this feels completely different from the
previous title the world's finest
assassin truly allowed rui sukio to
Showcase his talent in weaving together
an intriguing story along with
compelling characters it's one of the
better adaptations out there too so you
can go into this without worry about the
anime being a watered-down version of
the novel how's about a blast from the
past now with re-creators
I've been someone who's dabbled with the
creative side of things with the one to
make my manga or light novel recreaters
is a show that spoke to me it really
gives me a nice hypothetical as far as
content creators are concerned what if
our fictional characters are OCS
suddenly appear in the world what what
the is that working for and against
each other with their own agendas at
play now it looked to be a possible
Contender for breakout title of the year
when it aired but that ultimately didn't
come to fruition still at the show has a
lot of good to offer and it tries to jab
at many different genres in order to
ultimately give us a pretty creative
package done in the form of a reverse
isakai the presentation looks good the
concept of fictional worlds converging
in the real one is a really nice
proposition and it's got a banger of a
soundtrack too it's a show that tries to
go far with a cool premise while it fell
short of being the Blockbuster of its
year I do think that recreaters does
deserve recognition
foreign
needs no introduction does it
Sao discussion has been beaten to death
already for the past decade but I still
do think it deserves a spot on the list
for the sheer Legacy it brought with it
it's no granddaddy of Issa guy or
anything like that but it did break open
the floodgates and helped usher in the
isakai boom and taking a look at the
show in its own right it is still pretty
good in terms of production quality it's
easily one of a1's most beloved works
with alicization being a shining point
in terms of epic fight animation and
presentation it also explores some
themes that feel more and more relevant
the more time progresses with a heavy
emphasis on the melding of the real and
the virtual I feel like SEO can be a
fringe case because the way the other
world aspect was executed differed
greatly after the first Arc was done
wait a minute
who are you but there's no denying how
influential this title is to the world
of isakai you may have already watched
it but if you're still on the fence then
make sure you go for it don't forget to
watch the ordinal scale movie before
alicization 2.
and we're now officially at the halfway
point but for now hit that like button
if you've been enjoying the show it
helps the channel immensely and it will
help you get more videos like this on
your recommendations next up we have
sukimichi Moon fantasy
sometimes it's a guy protagonist just
get the short end of the stick you can
become the strongest being in the planet
with girls swooning over you and at
times you can just be as unfortunate as
makato deemed hideous by the goddess he
gets thrown into nowhere as far from the
human civilization as possible at the
very least he still has immense powers
that Captivate the numerous denizens of
the world it's pretty interesting to see
betrayed by a deity stories like this
take a light-hearted note from the
get-go you already know the tsukimichi
is a parody it's got the fights it's got
the tension but it leans really heavily
on the comedic territory it's got this
great balance between action and comedy
regardless and that's coming from a
studio that doesn't have a lot under
their resume in terms of action shows
tsukimichi is an underrated show that
you should definitely give a try
it just seems so right to put shows with
similar premises right next to each
other thus we go for shield hero a
popular light novel with the whole
betrayed protagonist setup however
Shield hero feels more similar to Ari
fioretta in terms of tone in the overall
edginess for shield hero my favorite
part has to be the relationship between
naofumi and raftalia the whole Revenge
block is a good impetus but a plot like
that feels incomplete without the
growing bond between our hero and his
traveling party it's something that I
feel sets us apart from the likes of
ifureta which gave more focus on the
cooler aspects of exploration and combat
as well as the fan service of course
it's unfortunate that the show didn't
get the sequel that it deserves season 2
exists but it just feels night and day
compared to the first one possibly
because the Revenge plot and the most
drastic character development points get
resolved in the first series still it is
overall a fun adventure that I'd gladly
recommend to anyone looking to get into
isago I'm looking forward to more Shield
hero
princess connect redive deserves a spot
on the list
well the fact that princess connect
redive is an isakai was never mentioned
in the 2 Series and a third season isn't
anywhere in sight so I guess it's time
to drop the bomb that yes this is an
it's a guy title
it looks like one already and it feels
like one mine is showing the main
character get transported into the
fantasy world now what I like about
Princess connect is how it does story
escalation it starts out as a fun
wholesome Adventure in a fantasy world
full of light-hearted moments meme
quality reaction faces and the like all
before shifting gears in the second
season and turning into a high Tempo
action series featuring a kingdom
conspiracy and some of the most
unexpectedly insane battle sequences
from an anime like this it helps a lot
if you played the princess connect
mobile game but the story and characters
are good enough to carry the series even
without that prior knowledge princess
connect for me is one of the shows that
set a new standard of quality for mobile
game adaptations and it's something that
I wouldn't hesitate to recommend
laughs
if you think history is cool You're
Gonna Love Drifters
foreign
taught us anything it's the adding
historical and legendary realm
characters and putting them in a
free-for-all makes for some good
entertainment and money so what if we
take a similar concept and turn the
violence up and sprinkle everything with
an outlandish sense of swagger that's
when you get Drifters from the same
genius that gave us housing came the
high octane action series and you can
easily see the similarities with this
one a Nifty thing about Drifters is that
despite the dark Ambiance the violence
and all it still tries to sell some
comedic aspects it's always there no
matter how mundane they may seem in the
form of historical in jokes or character
interactions it's more or less a bonus
if you did your homework and you get the
references but of course you're here for
action aren't you and it's all there in
its unrestrained Glory Drifters is a joy
to watch if you're in for that sort of
thing it's a crying shame that it didn't
get a proper sequel I found myself
wanting more and I'm sure that you'll do
so too Saga of Daniel did make a
statement when it aired
[Music]
thank you
a recurring semen it's a guy is the
challenge of facing a god-like being few
areas points to do so as well as Tanya
ruthless master of War when being X the
god in this world didn't take a liking
to a sociopathic salary man who makes it
a point to stick it back at the God and
Ascend the ranks of the Imperial Army in
the form he was stuck in the child like
Tanya Tanya does have an ace up her
sleeve in her goal of conquest and
that's the retained Knowledge from the
previous Life as a salaryman it
certainly sets up an interesting
conflict given the unsurmountable odds
God throws at Dania and her sheer will
to survive and overcome the show does
have a bleak atmosphere befitting of its
setting and it also offers a great look
what I feel has The Vibes of a case
study on Psychopathic characters there's
also an in-depth look at military
strategy that I'm sure fans of warfare
are going to end up loving a focus I
feel was a little bit lacking in game if
you like Saga of Daniel this next one
will be right up your alley
[Music]
foreign
Overlord features a ruthless villain
protagonist set to make his mark on the
world but this time it takes place in a
video game and has our protagonist take
on the mantle of eins the most powerful
skeletal Lich of all time viewers then
get to follow him in his exploits as
they learn more about the world and his
denizens Overlord and its core is a
character-driven story whether you look
at it from the perspective of eins and
how his current role in remaining shreds
of humanity converge or his servants who
all show undying love and loyal to him
but in different ways
overall Overlord is a refreshing take on
the trapped in the video game genre it
also got much of its Fanfare due to the
setup of having a villain protagonist
it's got a lot of things that people
just love out of these kinds of shows an
overpowered protagonist who's not afraid
to flex his power characters with
notable quirks and designs and themes
that run deeper than how you'd think of
them at first glance but honestly most
people are just here mainly for the cool
Factor
foreign
since you're on the topic of a dark
leader of a faction filled with loyal
servants how about Eminence in Shadow
[Music]
thank you
one of the newer hits Eminence in Shadow
wasted no time capturing the hearts of
anime fans a lot of it is credited to
how overbought it is how ironic it is to
the point of parody Or to the sheer meme
Factor it has it's a show that's not
intended to be taken so seriously and
thus goes all the way in upping the
insanity I mean there's a guy named perv
Asher for Pete's sakes if you take away
the irony to the whole thing however
there's still a lot to like about
Eminence and Shadow it's a show that's
built on moments and while some of these
supposedly awesome moments end up being
funny in a case of mood Whiplash they
still work well for me at least it has a
slow start you know but once things go
Full Throttle it's more than an ample
source of 30 minutes of entertainment I
look for every week as you can tell
evidence in Shadow is something that
only certain types of watches can get or
enjoy but for those in that Target
demographic it's one of the most fun
shows you'll be getting from the past
year or so but if you just want to see a
cool overpowered protagonist do awesome
stuff while ascending the power scale
minus the parody in irony slime's the
one for you
oh they are
[Music]
reincarnated as a slime plays the whole
issakai thing in a way straighter manner
it's a show that has all those fantasy
gimmicks and story beats you'd expect
with the added caveat of being a
genuinely interesting watch with epic
moments tear jerkers and a lot of cool
Powers being put on display the story of
rimaru's rise from a lowly slime to
arguably one of the more overpowered
isakai protagonists out there truly is
something a reason I liked reincarnated
as a slime in addition to the action of
the great battle choreography is the
sheer variety you have as a main cast
you've got a lot of different flavors of
characters to help spice up the
adventure all while enjoying what an
awesome lead rimaru is these characters
all bring with them their own degree of
wit humor and Charisma slime is pretty
simple and straightforward but at times
it may just be what you want a Carefree
simple Adventure in a bright colorful
world nothing that will slam you back to
the reality that is the world we live in
I said letting us enjoy an anime for
what it is a gateway to enjoy life or
feeling the thrill of epic moments
heartache from tear jerker moments and
the occasional introspection
oh look up
foreign
at this point in time the whole time
Loop plot is common knowledge for folks
who love anime people got to experience
it from Stein's gate and Madoka at the
start of the 2010s but I'd argue that
the one who put it in the realm of super
mainstream is none other than re-zero
unlike the previous two mentioned time
Loop shows re-zero decides to set
himself in a fantasy world a world full
of Marvel and danger as our hero Subaru
tries his best to survive and reach his
happy ending it's a dark mystery
thriller that's got a lot of action
suspense and most importantly characters
who people easily resonate with to which
it owes much of its popularity in my
opinion and guess what season 2 made
things even better we've got more
character moments more development and
finally some major progression in Subaru
and Amelia's relationship I mean in some
ways I enjoyed season one a lot better
because it felt more like a mystery
action thriller That season but the
second season just shows how much
re-zero is capable of in terms of
shattering genre barriers
[Applause]
and finally we close out strong with
mushoku tensei
the best way to close this out is what
people call the granddaddy of isakai
whether that title hole is true or not
isn't important after all no one can
deny how muchoku tensei influenced a lot
of the conventions that we see in a lot
of modern isakai you've got the setting
the way the main characters
reincarnation was set up and a lot of
other tropes who've all come to love
sure there are also themes and scenes
that have caused the series to have the
mixed reception from people but for
those who are able to look past that the
show's such a complete experience for
the genre you've got the World building
the thrill of exploration the story of
growth some nice action and insane fight
sequences and characters to get attached
to everything's then backed up by a
studio that's hell-bent on making the
series The Next Big Thing giving the
adaptation all the love and care it
needed to be a great way to introduce
people into the franchise there's not a
lot of shows that get this amount of
dedication from the anime team but the
folks couldn't have picked a better show
to join that kind of elite company
thank you
and that's it my top 20 picks for action
isakai in the modern context if you've
got some shows that you want to include
or you think I may have overlooked feel
free to tell me down in the comments
section below if you want more videos
like this the channel has them in Spades
thank you for watching all the way till
the end I hope you'll be back for more
there'll be more videos to come so stay
tuned